and as you guys know the iphone 13 pro
pro max have insane cameras but can they
keep up with a pro camera with dedicated
lenses today we will find out make sure
to grab a piece of paper and a pen
definitely play along with us on this
one because it's going to be a lot of
fun we would love to know your results
in the comments and we actually did this
video before with the s21 ultra and a
pro camera and the results were very
interesting but this time the iphone 13
pro's camera actually destroys the s21
so this is
very interesting with this test and i
actually had to go and get one lens for
the wide and the zooms and i had to get
a specialty manual lens to have wide
angle with macro capabilities so we're
going to look at these images blind and
as you guys suggested all of these
photos are taken with raw we have the
pro route with apple we have raw on the
camera we have the cinematic mode and s
log graded to make each camera look its
best so this is gonna be insane let's
start out with this first image right
here which one looks better for this
first one the difference is crazy and
you can instantly tell which is which i
really like the depth of the pro camera
because her hand is out of focus rather
than all of her yep and i did notice
actually that the iphone messed up the
blur right here to completely miss that
so it's pretty obvious yep yep you guys
are correct here's the next one it's
going to be a little bit tougher what do
you guys think wow that is this is so
close i actually have to like look up
close get even closer
oh yeah this is tough this is very
similar but i have a feeling that i like
the one on the right better i think it
did a better job with kind of more
texture and detail visible oh
the ultrawide got a lot better this year
a lot better here's our third shot
portrait wow this is very very close all
right
this is another one where you got to
look
oh man they're extremely similar the
detail everything they both look amazing
and when you look at your photos are you
gonna do are you gonna look that close
when they're on your phone so i'm
actually gonna be choosing the one on
the right for one reason it does a
better job with the highlights if you
look at the hair it's not as blown out
whereas this kind of has blown it here
and on the side of the face this is more
kind of i guess range of
i don't know brightness i don't know
i'll explain it i'm also going with the
right but more because to me the blur
looks more natural and i kind of like it
all right
oh geez
the crazy thing this is the new
telephoto lens which we love we love
that three times lens and all that blur
is fake everything's actually in focus
so all the nice
this how it disperses the blur and the
depth looks really good wow all right
what about some food guys i'm gonna go
with the right
are you sure about that is this your
final law finally i think because like
there's some issues with like
overexposure right here with these
what are they clams yeah to me they look
so similar it's insane yeah it is insane
i was actually going to go with the
right as well because i see a lot more
contrast right
oh seven
thing is you can add contrast with any
of them too all right what do you guys
think about this hmm look at that bokeh
wow
wow okay the one on the left obviously
kills it like look at that beautiful
beautiful bokeh and like everything pops
and i think these whatever the sculpture
is it kind of pops out more it's more
sharp i was gonna say that i thought the
iphone would fail in this instance this
this thing was so far away up in the air
you have all these blades that need to
be cut out you have all the background
how can an iphone make fake blur that
looks that good actually i don't even
know which one it is in this case i
completely forgot but let's see
a7s3 and here we have a macro shot macro
um i had i got close as close as the one
of the lenses allowed me to get yeah the
one on the right obviously obviously
kills it like it separates from the
background with the blur in the
background just totally better there you
go you guys are right that is the pro
camera again and it's tough because with
these pro cameras you have such a large
sensor that i actually did stop down to
match these as close as i could you
still get that blur which you don't with
the iphone and the next one is video so
as you guys know i did shoot video for
this that i shot the prores cinematic
and that takes up a lot of battery life
so in order to charge up your phone we
have a sponsor for this video finally we
have anchor we've been recommending them
for years now here you guys go check
these out
these are their new 511 chargers they're
nano pro it is 45 smaller than apple's
20 watt charger a lot smaller same size
as the 5 watt brick but it charges your
phone three times faster than that so
you get full fast charging you guys get
these awesome colors they actually have
four colors and they have these matching
cables check these out and feel these
for yourselves i pulled these out of the
box they feel amazing
and the quality is really nice as well
so i've been buying anchor for years
vadim has been buying anchor for years
they have active shield to monitor the
temperature and protect your device so
charge a fast and make it last with
anchor go and check these out down in
the video description below pick one up
charge your phone fast don't let video
shooting kill your battery charge up
quickly i want one thank you anchor we
love you guys and yeah check them out
and now let's go ahead and check out
this video clip
weird what do you guys think
how assassinating mode
interesting like the minimal focusing
distance or something but
man this is so obvious like
you can instantly tell that it's fake
blur here on the left and i don't know
what's going on with the dynamic range
like his skin is literally flat yep
everything's flat and gray
wow
so yeah still
still this is probably the most obvious
one we have cinematic mode on one and we
have the pro camera another which one
you guys choosing just make sure you
guys make a choice they're right
all right there you go that is the pro
camera yeah cinematic mode it looks like
not only is a limited 1080p
it doesn't do that hdr um shots when
it's doing always cinematic mode i don't
think cause look how terrible it looks
so in this situation it just looks like
garbage all right let's get into another
photo photo this is a portrait shot here
with the wide all right so in this photo
i'm definitely going with the one on the
left because i feel like it's more
lively and it kind of like pops like the
skin kind of glows
and you have like the contrast of colors
like in the grass yeah i absolutely
agree one of the biggest differences for
me that i noticed is that the one on the
right like distorts a lot especially in
the faces they definitely look yeah the
face looks a lot different huh yeah
that's true okay that is the pro camera
and another thing i didn't mention is
that this is also a 12 megapixel camera
so i matched it up to the iphone so
there's no
difference i guess in that
all right for me i instantly like the
one on the left just because of that the
depth i would say that i agree yeah i
like how the bowl is kind of more uh out
of focus blurred out and these kind of
glasses they really kind of pop that is
the pro camera again camera and i
actually stopped down i think like f16
or something
because at f 2.8 everything's blurred
out
but the iphone's 3x lens it actually
unless you're using portrait mode you
don't get any blur at all even here but
i don't know if you guys noticed the
dynamic range difference it actually
pulled that out
which yeah but that shot looks better
absolutely and now we have a three times
zoom shot all right and this one i am
definitely choosing the one on the right
i really like how the color tones pop
out like you got like these orange trees
over here and the one on the left kind
of keeps everything super flat i feel
like you can also see a lot more detail
on the one on the right
yeah it's interesting because it's
they're both 12 megapixel so it's not
resolution it's just maybe lens
differences
and you guys once again chose the pro
camera and take a look at this shot
right here i won't explain much but you
guys tell me what you think it has over
sharpening to the extreme on the left
wow
oh definitely the one on the right yeah
definitely the right like it's much more
natural looking without the over sharp
these blur more detail everywhere yeah
and that one is the pro camera once
again so this shot right here is
actually 15 times zoom on both that's
the most that the iphone can zoom in so
i actually have to do cropping later
with the sony and you just see the lens
how much sharper the lens bringing in
that extra detail looks more realistic
here's another portrait shot all right
and this one i'm looking at them and i
think i would rather go for the one
on the right i feel like the one on the
left is a little bit kind of uh flat
looking and i really like the blur and
just the bokeh look on the background on
the right so i'm going with that one i
think the one on the right is the iphone
just because once again like the
distortion for portrait mode however i
do think it looks nicer i like
back here how it's not as blown out it's
not as like crazy in your face it looks
really nice and soft yeah that looks
really good angelica you are correct
that is the iphone it did an amazing job
and that sun the dynamic range there
that sunset looks way better than just
the harshness there and you guys don't
see that this was in the shade like
really dark shades but i added these to
look their best so good and we got
another porch right here i'm gonna go
for the one on the left for this one i
think i agree so one thing that i
noticed was
if you look at the uh the light on her
face it looks very flat and the skin
tones are lacking pro camera once again
one thing hasn't mentioned look at the
distortion on her head
compared to here so you got to be so
careful on the iphone with that wide
angle standard camera when you can porsh
like these because it can distort the
image and now we got a selfie portrait
selfie honestly these both look pretty
good i'm gonna go with the one on
the left because there's just a lot more
detail but the one on the right looks
looks pretty darn good yeah they both do
an excellent job and i agree with
angelica i'm going with the one on the
left for a couple of reasons i see more
kind of texture and there are some weird
little things around hair where you can
notice like little
messes up with the portrait mode yeah
left for sure you guys got the pro
camera again you guys you guys have
really good eyes incredible eyes i'm
really curious to hear what the audience
has to say i would just want to point
out that
that bokeh like that looks better bokeh
to me nice smoother less distracting
than over here even though yeah the edge
cutting out isn't correct and even
though you guys are choosing the iphone
the pro camera often it's incredible how
the iphone's doing oh yeah ultrawide
shot here wow
oh the one on the right for me
the just because of the dynamic range
yeah i do agree the one on the right you
see kind of more texture it's not like
blown out ish on the uh
on the wood as well as the sky and the
highlight roll-off on her face does
better too so
that is the pro camera again and even
though the ultrawide got better this
year
it seems like the dynamic range in the
ultrawide is not as good as a standard
camera so that's why i was not able to
recover that even though it was pro raw
interesting and here we have another
video both of these this is an insanely
difficult situation super bright sun
really dark shadows where we're in and
hiding inside of trees go ahead and
watch it
you see that is that like oh look at the
artifacts like crazy
wow it's literally like noise everywhere
the whole time all over the whole thing
yeah the one on the right is very clean
and much more detail in the trees too so
yeah the right kills it yep so
that one is the pro camera okay now it
did blow out the sky more so yeah then
so the iphone really trying to get that
dynamic range
um and because of that it was had a lot
of noise and a lot of artifacts whereas
the sony here this was actually s-log
three i graded it myself okay i chose to
properly expose this and so your dynamic
range is actually worse but the image is
a lot better and here is another
portrait shot for you guys
this is a tough one wow if you guys have
to look for that long and that close i
say that's a win for the iphone it's
definitely a win yeah these are both
super similar i'm going with the one on
the left because it looks a lot more
natural
um like you can tell in a couple spots
on the right that it's using portrait
mode but yeah and a year or two ago this
would be a nightmare
garbage yeah it messes up everywhere
and got the pro camera again and here is
an ultra wide shot
crazy dynamic range sun peeking out
behind the trees wow okay i feel like i
see more a lot more detail on the left
but dang these both look really similar
they both look so good i have to come
fast and say that
a lot of these shots i thought the
iphone would look way worse like way
worse compared to raw and editing them
to look the best it's just shocking to
see so what the result was yeah crazy
pro cameras so similar you guys have
eagle eyes eagle eyes but yeah so i
guess the ultrawide could still use some
work on the iphone and now we got a
portrait shot right here crazy tough
situation like the toughest you could do
they both do very well
that's interesting like literally leaves
are in the air
that is
impressive i really like how everything
is so blurry in the back and all these
leaves are like they really stand out
and they seem like
the kids are in focus
more to me yeah honestly i'm gonna go
with left like i like the extra depth of
field and like
your kids really pop out in the photo
and just yeah i like
yeah
that is the iphone we got one for the
iphone that looks so good
the fake both of us because everything's
actually in focus it looks amazing
that's way better than this real bokeh
that's a little bit distracting and
harsh
now one issue i had like we spent like
five minutes taking this photo like over
and over
that when you take a portrait shot with
the iphone it always lags behind like a
second after you press the button so
even though i press the button exact
same time
you know that's the result it kind of
gets a little annoying
all right we got another portrait shot
here with a three times lens on both
honestly look i'm looking at these i'm
going with one on the left i really like
how the leaves are not blurred out and
the skin tones much better job here like
everything's just so natural just
rolling off i'm going with the right but
honestly i would be really happy to have
either of these yeah i was i was shocked
by how good this was and also we're not
a lot of these we're not mentioning uh
edge issues because there are none the
iphone just got insane at cutting out
yeah
got another iphone
yes
and we got this flag shot okay wow once
again no blur issues here
no issues that's insane these look like
pretty much the same photo like they
look the same yeah that's so close one
costs you a thousand dollars and you get
a whole phone the other costs you five
and a half thousand dollars and you
don't get a phone
i can't pick i i seriously can't they
both look they look the same to me like
yeah how can you have a preference
okay i do have one preference i am gonna
go with the left because i do notice
some really nice pokeballs all around
this tree i really like that all right
listen let's see which pokeballs you
prefer iphone or sony
sony
and this is like the toughest portrait
situation for any phone and even cameras
it's very hard
yeah just just so much better the one on
the right just suffering from so much
flaring that just makes everything gray
left for sure sony you got nice coatings
on those nice optics super nice if not
for the flaring they'd be like the same
and this shot right here we have crazy
dynamic range super shadows with super
bright sunset i mean i've got to give
this to the one on the left uh it
doesn't have as much flaring and um i do
feel like you have a brighter
kind of shadows like with the truck the
white really stands out more so i am too
just because of the sky in the sun but
other than that they literally look this
the same to me
you guys chose the iphone so last shot
we had more flaring with the telephoto
lens but with the standard lens look at
all the flaring here
right you have all these lines where now
the iphone's really struggled in the
past that flaring has been so minimized
and now we have this handheld
shot whoa okay of
the dark and it was literally pitch
black for this photo i mean well it's
crazy
oh man i
see you see more stars here but just so
much motion blur on these trees they're
just really smeared whereas on the right
you have much more detail in the trees
here trees in the background everything
more detail i'm going for the right i'm
right absolutely going for the left i
think that one looks way nicer even
though
it doesn't look as detailed and like
motion blurry whatever i'd much rather
have that there you guys go
so vadim chose the iphone of course we
have the night mode where it's literally
taking 10 seconds of images it's so dark
stacking them and on the sony i had to
use so much noise reduction i took a
bunch of photos try to get the minimum
shutter speed to minimize iso it was way
harder than just pressing a button
and a lot of editing too
and is a three times shot that night
yeah this is definitely the one on the
right there's a lot of noise massive
amounts of noise here and in the in the
uh lawn mower and just the over
sharpening yeah
yep the pro camera that three times lens
does not do that great at night and we
have another video with low light
scenario so let's take a look
all right right off the bat i'm seeing
more kind of color roll off with that
light bulb it's really bringing the
colors out so i'm seeing a lot of noise
on the left
and just more detail in general on the
right
so
definitely choosing the right yeah and
i'm noticing a lot more depth on the
right one as well
all right that is
the pro camera and this actually the
best case scenario with the standard
lens shooting pro res
not the compression it'd be way worse if
it was not pro res on the iphone that's
the new you know lens with the f15 so
like the other languages would be worse
and now let's get into some night mode
shots so here you guys go all right this
is a very interesting one i'm seeing
some differences
i kind of feel like the one on the left
has more visible detail which is really
nice however a lot of the highlights are
completely blown out like this whole
thing looks like a bar
all the way around and that yellow color
at the top is completely white whereas
the yellow actually pops out here and
just roll off of
yeah so ah this is tough i'm going with
the one on the left but both of these
are very very similar i'm gonna go right
and this is ultra wide which suffers
more whichever one's iphone oh i chose
the other so vadim chose the iphone it
did good i like how it does yeah yeah
stacking 10 images or so really helps
out and here we have another shot
what do you see
whoa weird i mean it's got to be the
right i mean look at it it actually
brings out the colors and the glow of
that sign and so much more detail
everywhere like look at this whole thing
all that texture
easily the right i mean i was gonna say
how like i liked the sign more just how
it's like it pops out a lot more but all
the detail and everything else yeah the
right
and the right is the pro camera and it's
interesting in this shot you see jaggedy
edges not a lot of detail the iphone is
actually using the main camera cropping
in now instead of a three times lens
which is what the shot was
and we have this beautiful night mode
shot
wow okay that's impressive they're both
so close but i am seeing some
differences there is more detail on the
one on the right like if you look at
this pavement more texture more detail
and on top of that it does better with
dynamic range if you look at all these
crazy bright lights inside the building
so easily the right i'm going with the
left i think the left one looks a lot
nicer actually
all right so vadim chose the iphone and
jacket shows the pro camera the sony
yeah with that night mode that's cool i
could not even taking a raw photo
manipulating it i could not get the same
amount of detail because you have
denoising you have to do all that so if
you can't stack a bunch of images like
the iphone is you can't maximize that
dynamic range and detail which is crazy
and now we have another one here with
the three times lens same thing as
before a lot more detail in all the
concrete and like look at that sign my
fresh basket you can actually see the
color and it's much more sharp i'm still
going with the one on the left for me
same thing we got the iphone redeemed
the pro camera for honestly killer job
iphone apple you guys are crazy and we
have a nighttime portrait shot here this
is tough i'm gonna go with the right
just because i feel like there's more
depth to it but they're both very very
close yeah i'm also going with the one
on the right i like um
the detail and i like all those nice
pokeballs on the outside with those
lights looks really good and there's no
motion blur like on the face where there
is here like some weird softness motion
blur it also messed up a little bit here
good eyes guys very good eyes
and we got a portrait shot
yeah i mean yeah
yeah you don't even have to
just the right and that's the best i
could get it to be edited it's just wow
when you're doing portrait all the
computational photography and you don't
get the night stuff together
yeah
of course pro camera way better for that
and we got a standard shot of a
different object here you've got a
little bunny they both look really
really good yeah i was surprised by how
good the bokeh is whichever one is fake
i actually don't even remember it so
they look yeah they're so close like how
do you get bokeh that's that
realistic-looking yeah they must
research all the time it's crazy yeah
i'm gonna go with the uh the right if
you look at the close details there's so
much more of this texture pops out here
yeah i'm choosing this one yeah i'm
going with the left
all right vadim loves the iphone
the detail yeah that night mode portrait
capability really good which only the
pro has is great
and we have a shot here
interesting interesting i mean it's the
one on the left easily i mean look how
nice that looks you have the depth of
field you have all the pokeballs they
really stand out and of course that is
the pro camera now this was supposed to
be a portrait shot and i guess for some
reason the iphone just couldn't pull it
off really it looked like it showed the
blur was going to kick in
but you just can't do porch you cannot
get an image like this where you're far
away and you still get blur you have to
be much closer and you get that
distortion
and this is a 3x
it's crazy pitch black crazy situation
here really i mean the one on the right
is obviously better look at it like uh
look at all the detail and noah emily it
doesn't have all that smearing one on
the right pro camera once again yeah and
this image actually i i probably spent
about five minutes editing this one
image because it looked like garbage out
of the camera like garbage i was like
the iphone's gonna smoke
but once you do a lot of work you have a
lot to work with there
and this is our last one ultra wide shot
here at night it's crazy to me how
similar they are like all these photos
because if if they were taken with like
the 12 instead there'd be a much much
bigger difference a lot of these are
almost identical i have to go like super
super close up yeah i'm choosing the one
on the left because if you look at these
little bushes here this is completely
blacked out right here you actually have
some texture coming out and the stars
stand out more but they're almost like
the same photo photo to me
pro camera camera all right guys that is
the last shot so
go ahead and count up what you guys got
how often did you choose the pro camera
or how often do you choose um the iphone
we want to hear your guys's opinions
we'll wait just a second longer you guys
go ahead and vote and now let's go first
with vadim alrighty so i got 25 for the
pro camera and 11
for the 13 pro
so you're saying that
11 times out of the that whole amount
that we had yeah the iphone actually
tricked you and did better than a five
and a half thousand dollar set actually
gave us
which is insane and what about you
angelica
i got 30 for the pro camera and six for
the iphone wow but honestly a lot of
those were like very close very very
close so close enough that it i wouldn't
even choose one over the other and we do
these a lot yeah oh yeah we do these a
lot we know what to look for and i as
the person taking these images and
making them look their best coming into
this i thought the iphone would get
smoked i literally thought the iphone
looked much worse than so many of these
shots when i was taking them like this
is a crazy situation
but
it didn't look that much worse they were
kind of close and then there's some
cases at night mode
i was just shocked by how much better
the iphone looked and with a lot of
editing i got the sony photos to look
close to as good as the iphone lots of
it compared to pressing one button and
waiting and you're done so
he spent a full day
yeah i'm more of an iphone believer now
than i was before which is crazy so we
want to hear your guys opinions what
were your thoughts once again go ahead
and check out the anker 511 charger
their nano pro
we have the links down below thank you
anchor for working with us even though
we've been recommend you guys anyways
for years so you guys can click above to
subscribe to help us reach our goal of 1
million subscribers that would be
amazing check out one of the great
videos right over there this one max
angelica and vadim and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]